factor by grouping and we have 5 rs plus
25r minus 3s minus 15. and the reason
why we're going to factor by grouping
we're going to see in a second what that
entails is that there's no common factor
to all four of these terms if you just
look at these first two terms they both
are divisible by 5 both by r only only
one of them is divisible by s but
they're both divided by far at 5r so
there's a common factor but then if you
go to this third term here it's neither
divided by r or by 5. and then when you
go to this term over here it's divided
by 5 but not by r so when we factor by
grouping what we want to do is group
these into what we're going to see as
two groups of two so that each group can
kind of be factored a little bit and
then see if we can kind of keep
undistributing the property to simplify
this so we could do is we could say
like we just saw that 5rs and 25r
they're both divisible by
5 and r so let's kind of group those two
together so list 5rs
plus
25r we're going to group those guys
together and then we have and then we
have the
minus 3s
minus 15. and these are good to group
together because at least they're both
divisible by 3 they're not both
divisible by s or by five but they're
both divisible by three so maybe we can
make a little headway over there so
let's so let's just group so let's we
could put a plus and then we can group
those two together just like that when
we do that it becomes easier to factor
things out both of these terms are
divisible by 5.
both of these terms are divisible by r
they're not both divisible by s so all
we can factor out is a 5r the greatest
common factor of 5rs and 25r is just 5r
so it's going to be 5r times if you
factor out 5r from this if you take out
5r from 5rs all you're going to have
left is the s or another thing but if
you divide this by 5r all you're going
to have left is the s
if you take out a 5r here or you divide
this by 5r what are you going to have 25
divided by 5 is 5.
r divided by r is 1. so if you take out
a 5r out of this term you're just going
to be left with a 5. now let's do this
second term now what can we factor out
here
well both terms are divisible by 3 or
even better we can say that they're both
divisible by negative three that way
we'll kind of we'll we'll get rid of
these negative signs and that's about it
only one is divisible by s and only the
other one is divisible by five so let's
take a negative three out of both of
them
negative three if you factor out the
negative 3 out of this all you're going
to have left is the s or if you divide
this expression right here by negative 3
you're just going to be left with s if
you take negative 15 and you factor out
a negative 3 or if you divide that by
negative 3 you're just going to be left
with a positive
a positive 5. so now we have something
interesting now we essentially have if
you look at this higher level we now
have two we can't really you know these
these each of these terms are the
product of of of a monomial and another
binomial but we have these two parts of
the expression now and notice both of
these parts are both divisible by s plus
five they're both multiples of s plus
five so now we can factor out an s plus
we have a 5r times s plus 5 and we have
negative 3 times s plus 5. so let's
factor out an s plus 5.
so if you factor out an s plus 5. so
we're literally just factoring it out
then this term over here if you factor
out the s plus 5 you're just going to be
left with the 5r
and then this term over here if you
factor out the s plus 5 you're just
going to be left with the negative 3. so
you're going to have a plus negative 3
or you could just write that literally
as adding a negative 3 is the same thing
as subtracting a 3. and so we've
completely factored this we get it we
get s plus 5 times 5 r
minus 3. now what i want to show you is
that we could have actually switched
these middle terms because we would
still had groups that are factorable so
let's try that out just to see that we
could have done it other ways so i could
have written this as
5 rs now let's swap these minus 3s
plus 25r
minus 15 and i could have grouped it
this way i could have grouped these guys
together and then i could have grouped
these guys together and this would still
work because these two guys still have
some common factors and these two guys
also have a few common factors
over here they're both divisible by well
let's see only one is divisible by five
only one of them is divisible by r but
they're both divisible by s so we can
factor out an s so this term could be s
times five r minus three
plus now over here both of these are
divisible by 5 and that's it so we could
factor out a 5.
25 r divided by 5 is going to be 5r
negative 15 divided by 5 is going to be
negative 3.
now once again notice both of these
terms over here are divisible by 5r
are divisible by 5r minus 3. so let's
factor that out so we're going to factor
out a 5r minus 3.
5r minus 3.
so this term over here if you divide by
5r minus 3 you're just going to be left
with an s
and then this term over here if you
factor out a 5r minus 3 you're going to
just be left with a 5. so s plus 5 and
we got the same exact result when we
grouped it in a different way